l'argent et tu me manques dans la mesure
où je ne peux pas disons faire certaines
choses qui me serait utile pour mon pour
mon travail mais toute façon j'ai rien
du tout j'ai pas de maison à la campagne
j'ai pas de jets pas de voiture de sport
je m'en fous complètement ce qui
m'intéresse beaucoup c'est d'avoir une
guitare un piano
ce qui m'inquiète ce canton vient par
exemple si on vient à me saisir des
choses actuellement chez moi ça met un
petit peu un petit peu égal ce que ce
que je voudrais c'est qu'on vienne pas
me saisir ma tête enfin je te dire que
jusqu'à présent on n'a pas trouvé encore
le système peut être qu'un géant 3 le
système de dévisser en tête avec 4
petits boulots qu'il enlevait la sur la
chaussée très embêté et jeu j'aurai
besoin de beaucoup d'argent je crois
pour la récupérer ça fera une belle
affiche 1
peut-être
vous avez véritablement l'intention de
quitter la france
les tendances de la musique française me
pousse à partir pour un pays où la
musique ressemble plus à ce que je fais
qu'est ce que vous reprochez précisément
à la chanson française par exemple ans
je reproche je reproche rien de spécial
avec fond c'est à dire je trouve qu'il
ya une impossibilité actuellement
d'évoluer et si par exemple je suis
actuellement les chemins qu'elle qu'elle
présente
moi j'ai l'impression de tricher parce
que ça ne correspond plus à du tout à ce
que j'aime
donc je n'ai jamais triché futur fais ce
que j'aime est un moment je les fais mon
dernier disque love you because est très
mauvais c'est le commencement pour moi
disons d'un nouveau tournant car c'est
bien parce que je me suis rendu compte
qu'il était mauvais après l'avoir sorti
vous avez l'impression que vous allez
pouvoir apprendre quelque chose il est
certain il est certain que en france je
ne plains ce temps je n'apprends rien du
tout j'ai besoin actuellement de me
retrouver dans une sorte de compétition
mais qui n'est pas une compétition de
gens qui se détestent qui est une
compétition de gens qui aiment la même
chose à dire la musique et que qui aime
notamment le rock'n'roll qui qui
s'appelle pantomime rock ou qui
s'appellera redois que des choses comme
ça représente une musique qui
m'intéresse là-bas ya des gens qui sont
très très fort et je préfère vraiment
car je prends des risques évidemment en
partant états unis je préfère être un
artiste méconnu dans une musique que
j'aime plutôt que joe dette de quelque
chose que je n'aime plus je dois dire
que je ne sais pas du tout ce qui va se
passer là bas c'est ça qui me fascine et
qui me passionne j'avais absolument à
laventure et la musique américaine est
quelque chose de fascinant cachot deux
écus la musique qui actuellement en
france est quelque chose qui répond à
des besoins qui sont je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs actuellement ce qui se passe
si vraiment les disques qui marchent
sont les disques que le public aime
vraiment où finalement s'il n'a pas le
choix si on lui permet pas si les
intermédiaires ne lui permettent pas
d'écouter finalement ce qu'il aimerait
entendre ça je ne sais pas c'est
difficile à savoir
je ne chanterai plus en français je
n'enregistre plus en français car le
français est une langue qui se prête mal
à la musique que
que j'aime faire et jusqu'à présent
j'avais toujours le savions depuis
longtemps ça je savais depuis longtemps
mais jusqu'à présent j'arrivais dix ans
à trouver des mots français qui
s'approchait le plus possible des zones
arides une anglaise
disons que le à peu près maintenant ne
me suffit plus et que je veux faire
quelque chose qui me satisfasse
pleinement
effectivement souvent j'ai eu des
problèmes dans mes spectacles souvent
j'ai quitté la scène mais finalement
c'était parce que j'avais le sentiment
de ne pas présenter au public le tue ce
que je pensais qu'il méritait d'avoir
c'est votre décision de quitter la
france n'est pas des gens consécutive à
une forme de deux fois sur dix ans je ne
peux pas dire que je suis en pleine
forme morale parce que c'est toujours
quand même surpris non non mais oui mais
vous c'est le physique et le moral sont
deux choses totalement différentes je
pense que c'est une chose assez connue
maintenant disons que il ya des gens
comme ça qui n'ont qui n'ont rien et qui
se sentent mal en admettant qu'on se
donne rendez-vous dans un an qu'est ce
que vous souhaitez être dans un an à
dans un an je souhaite vraiment
sincèrement faire la musique que j'aime
et ça c'est très important pour un
créateur je crois que si je voulais
actuellement je pourrais tricher et
tromper tout le monde je suis assez
intelligent pour pour ça mais je crois
que il faut avant tout vraiment avant le
succès qu'ont qu'on souhaite il faut se
choisir la faim de succès qu'on veut je
je crois que la musique est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire n'y a pas de
musique mineure il ya de la bonne ou
mauvaise musique est ce que je veux
c'est avoir du succès avec de la bonne
musique
il souhaite plutôt si c'est non non
chi l'ha
je sais
6 heures
une loi que bret
en fin de vie